dans les studios de la belle de mai à
marseille accueilli aujourd'hui les
premières séquences du feuilleton de la
rentrée sur france 3 feuilleton baptisé
plus belle la vie c'est un marathon
télévisuel qui commence puisque cinq
épisodes par semaine seront produits
tout au long de l'année un projet qui se
veut ambitieux avec notamment la volonté
de recréer un feuilleton populaire comme
on n'en fait plus depuis les années 60
olivier chartier delaigue et louis
aubert était là lors du premier clap
attention 3,2 à action à marseille sur
les plateaux de la belle de mai la
télévision fait son cinéma premier jour
de tournage pour le nouveau feuilleton
de france 3 plus belle la vie à la
rentrée les téléspectateurs découvriront
cette saga à raison de cinq épisodes par
semaine pour les acteurs et les
techniciens c'est un marathon qu'ils
commencent
entre angoisse et excitation
si jamais il y a un petit accrochage sur
une phrase oui pas de drame on continue
on fera un pick up sur la phrase ce
n'est pas dramatique
22 minutes de fictions télévisées à
produire chaque jour l'équipe n'a pas
vraiment le temps de souffler seule
solution pour tenir la cadence imposée
les séquences sont tournées en longueur
par trois caméras travaillant de façon
simultanée l'essentiel du montage se
fait en temps réel à mesure que les
acteurs jouent sur le plateau pour nous
c'est un travail qui est peut-être un
tout petit peu plus proche du théâtre
que les tournages habituels ou en coupe
beaucoup plus là en travers dans ses 15
dont contrats aidés scène
là c'est connu et du jeu du comédien
c'est quelque chose d'un petit peu
différente d'un tournage classique
jour après jour colette renard michel
cordes sylvie flepp et toute la troupe
de comédiens donneront vie au quartier
du mistral les habitants de ce petit
coin de marseille réinventer deviendront
bientôt les voisins de la france entière
mais j'aimerais trop rare le panier pour
voir justement le lieu de tournage de
plus belle la vie vont garder accroc
depuis deux ans aurait tout à fait c'est
pour ça que j'ai voulu venir ici à
marseille et pourtant nous avons cherché
partout mais à marseille le quartier du
mistral est introuvable beaucoup de gens
qu'un teaser et qui cherche le quartier
du mistral le bar du mistral et
malheureusement dans leur esprit que ça
n'existe pas d'ailleurs je fais un appel
aux bonnes volontés s'il y avait
quelqu'un qui est la bonne idée
d'installer un bar du mistral sur le
vieux porche parce qu'il fait fortune
après avoir bien cherché nous l'avons
trouvé le quartier du mistral existe bel
et bien oui dans des studios à l'abri
des regards des touristes à l'exception
de ces petits veinards de saône et loire
qui ont gagné un bus spécialement oui on
restera de trois jours profitez de mars
et pour nous c'est un petit peu une
consécration parce que c'est
montrer que
les gens croient à la vie qu'on présente
tous les jours et comme c'était vraiment
la volonté qu'on avait au départ c'était
de montrer un vrai quartier avec des
vrais gens
voilà la boucle est bouclée les gens ont
la sensation que ce quartier existe et
que les protagonistes ils pourront les
trouver au coin de la rue quelque part
dans marseille
plus belle la vie le feuilleton à
changer le regard que les touristes
porte sur marseille un véritable succès
puisque demain soir la chaîne diffusera
le 500e épisode
[Musique]